did the pandemic actually save stargate
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so the background as we all know is that
brad wright has been planning a new
stargate series for about three years
now mgm and amazon are still
collectively working on the project brad
i started all those years ago
and they are actually if you are a
regular to the channel you'll know about
this working on a second project as well
now they're not going to make both of
these tv series but amazon are wanting
brad wright and the mgm team to think a
lot bigger and this second project
really is showing brad right what could
be done but why do i say that the
pandemic possibly saved stargate
well
it is true that mgm three years ago were
pushing for stargate to get made they're
really pushing for this because stargate
is one of their biggest franchises it's
actually second only to james bond so
they really wanted to increase the value
of mgm towards the sale to have a
stargate project in the works because
the intellectual property of stargate or
as a back catalogue stargate is worth so
much but as an actual project in the
works it's worth significantly more but
that series would have been brad
wright's total vision at that time and
it would have been set to a certain
budget you have to understand see mgm is
2 billion quid in debt they're actually
owned by their debtors
amazon are buying them for nearly nine
billion but part of that deal can
actually increase because they're also
agreeing to pay for certain debts mgm
would have had to have produced brad
wright's version of this stargate series
to a budget
and that budget would have been quite
limited i actually believe that's one of
the reasons why brad wright was looking
at this stargate academy because he has
to produce a stargate series a certain
set of limits
now amazon are coming in and saying
there are no limits money has become far
less of a problem all of a sudden and
you can think a lot bigger this is why
we're seeing so many different ideas
bouncing around mgm at the moment and
that my sources at mgm keep coming at me
with new things constantly they're
saying they're even thinking now about
an ancients prequel series they're
thinking about movies they're thinking
about more than one series they're
actually developing or very early stages
developing two series at the moment in
the hope that it'll merge into one new
much bigger much more dramatic series
than brad wright originally envisaged so
i'm now i'm gonna put a poll on my
community channel i will put a link in
the description that poll is going to be
very very simple do you think the
pandemic possibly saved stargate because
think about this
if stargate had been made two and a half
years ago
an upside of that is that we'd be now
probably looking forward to the second
series
but the series would have been made the
way brad wright wanted and then amazon
would have come in
afterwards
potentially halfway through or towards
the end of the first series being filmed
and if they'd have come in and not liked
what they saw
that series would have almost certainly
been cancelled and i personally believe
that would have been the final death
nail in stargate
i don't think we would have ever seen it
again
because of the pandemic that series got
put on pause
amazon have been able to come in
get their feet under the table and start
actually talking to mgm about what they
would want
the executives at amazon can speak to
the executives at mgm and regardless of
what the final merger looks like they
now have far more influence on what the
final product will be and generally i
believe that product will be much bigger
and much more ambitious than what we
would have seen three years ago if the
pandemic hadn't happened
so did the pandemic save stargate please
get in the comments tell me what you
think and go and vote on the poll i
really really want to see what the
people think about this idea
if you are new to sidetrack please like
subscribe hit the bell notification
thumbs up thumbs down thumbs down help
nobody and please consider supporting
the channel you can become a fully
fledged side
hit the join button
as always guys please stay safe i'll see